so the surfrider foundation is really
interesting in a couple of different
angles one is that we focus on a very
thin swath of land we're really not
focused on the ocean and we're also
really not focused on the inland issues
we're focused on coastal issues you
could almost use a metaphor as kind of
beach zones so beach towns inland issues
waves and nearshore issues things like
that that focus is really important for
us because all of us live in coastal
regions most of us have lived there our
entire lives and what's happening is
super important to us which is why
people act hour after hour after hour
volunteering for something that they
care about so surfrider foundation was
started 25 years ago by three guys that
basically cared to preserve Malibu you
know the famed beach where bitch where
digit was filmed and fast forward to
today and that's what we're doing we're
doing that same thing day in and day out
all over the world
because I think environmentalism and a
lot of in a lot of ways has been seen as
this protectionist only thing you know
you can't cross this velvet line you
actually can't go in and see these
redwoods you can't participate in nature
and we're action sports people i mean i
broke my hand my smash my wrist couple
days ago skateboarding we're users so
we're out there paddling we see dolphins
going by I mean we want to protect and
preserve and enjoy the oceans waves and
peaches so it is both it's not just
protection it's also enjoyment yes but
more than that we're protecting it
because it needs to be protected because
no one else is protecting it but we're
also a user group so we have a you know
a very strong personal visceral
relationship with the environment I've
tried to find another group like this
that's actually submerged in the
elements you know we're not we're not
yachtsman who are going across the water
we're actually diving underneath the
water and we're riding the power of the
waves it's pretty unique
I sit at the bottom of a pyramid so you
look at a pyramid upside down at the
very top is 10 tens of thousands of
people all over the world essentially
fighting for coastal environmental
issues activist volunteers all kinds of
people like that and it's all over the
world and that's the surfrider
foundation is tens of thousands of
people all over the world fighting on
behalf of beach access pollution water
quality all those things and at the very
bottom of that pyramid is me and then
the board of directors and the reason
that it's an inverse pyramid is because
the power is truly wielded at the top
with all those people and not really me
what I'm more of doing is making sure
that our alignment our procedures are
processes or tool sets or communication
infrastructure all those things are
forward-looking and five years out in 10
years out but the real muscle is on the
edge so I work at Surfrider Foundation
the environment sparked my interest as a
kid I mean I don't know how you can grow
up in any setting other than maybe a
completely urban setting and not be
completely transfixed by the environment
playing in the waves playing in the
forest anything I mean the environment
is the world's largest playground and
it's pretty much free everywhere so you
know you don't necessarily need an xbox
although they are pretty fun the
environment is I think taps kids
imaginations more than anything so let's
say with me
I'm a tech guy I'm a kind of a tech
weenie was in technology for the last 20
years last two decades and I was called
by surf rider by the headhunter who said
you know the board of directors would be
interested in talking to you about
running surfrider foundation I said well
I'm totally the wrong guy I'm not a tech
I'm not a policy wonk I'm not all these
other things but I adore that brand I
adore that vision of the protection and
enjoyment of ocean waves and beaches it
is who I am it's an extension of my core
belief system so I basically went in and
talked with the board and told them I
wasn't their guy and that dialogue
lasted about six months and about four
months into it they convinced me that I
might be the person so they found me I
wasn't looking for it but I'm glad to be
here the joy in what I do is knowing
that it's much larger than me I work for
an idea it would be similar to is if I
worked with you know equal rights and
Martin Luther King or for free speech or
for non slavery issues it's a big idea
and just being a part of it is an honor
it's an absolute honor so the joy is
driving home every day and losing sleep
and not knowing not caring if you're
losing sleep but actually be stoked
about that that you're involved in
something much larger than yourself and
that your role is actually pretty
insignificant as an individual but as
part of a collective it's huge the
struggle and what I do is understanding
that we are late to the party we're
arrogant as a population we have hubris
which is stunning and I'm not just
talking about Americans I'm talking
about all of us my biggest struggle is
if we will actually understand what's at
stake and act instead of watching
another Britney Spears tabloid tragedy
you know those things are such chafe the
britney spears things when the media
issues
are really really important you know for
the next 10 years in next 50 years and
and on